details
[music
] more than 89,000 conscripts have already been sent to duty
stations conscription
activities
are carried out by military commissariats in a
planned manner
military teams are formed in a
timely manner to merge edits of recruits
no set task for conscripting citizens
will be completed before July 15 in
full, in addition, I note that the retired
conscripts are due  return to
places of residence as I said earlier
conscripts are not
sent to the zones of the
special military operation
[music] the
bill introduces the obligation of the
organization to conclude contracts in order to
ensure
other counter-terrorist operations
outside the territory of the Russian
Federation and also grant the right to
performers to purchase
products
necessary to fulfill the
state defense order  from the sole
supplier
[music]